[Music]
in a kurdish run jail in northern syria
the young muslim convert dubbed jihadi
jack
arrives to give his first interview
since his parents back home in oxford
were convicted of funding terrorism
by sending him money two
60 year old atheists being convicted for
islamic terrorism doesn't really make
much sense
i feel guilty for what i put them
through really that being said they
didn't actually do anything wrong they
sent me money to
leave etc and they didn't actually it's
not like they were actually funding some
sort of terrorist
activities jack letts was only a
schoolboy when he left home in may 2014
saying he wanted to learn arabic in
jordan
but four months later to his mother's
horror
he called home to say he was in syria i
wanted to fight the regime
and i never fought anyone except for the
regime but he says
he became disillusioned i left at a time
when
isis wasn't actually falling in on
itself i left because i opposed them i
genuinely opposed them i was played in
prison three times by isis
and then escaped from them if that makes
sense being against the regime i think
is a good thing but i definitely was
with the wrong people and that's
something i learned a long time ago now
he wants to come home
i know it doesn't it seems a bit
far-fetched at the moment but i'd love
to go home
britain's my home of course i'd want to
go home the british people like i said
they're my people but
i'm not sure they'd agree with that but
i have no intention of blowing them up
that's probably important
but this is a man who in an interview
last year said he would have been
prepared to detonate a suicide car bomb
when living in the former islamic state
stronghold of raqqa
attempts were made to de-radicalize jack
in 2015 and 16
but government funding was withdrawn
people like jack
and shamima begum there will always be a
threat
until you know one can assess them you
know one can work with them
i'm not one to say you know let's work
them with open arms i'd say let's put
them through due process
let's assess the risk this you know
protect the public and
and our country from any kind of risk
that these people would pose but also
look at them as an opportunity
to rehabilitate reintegrate but also use
them as
as tools to prevent others from falling
foul
to a narrative like isis our questions
were put to jack by a local journalist
the 23 year old has already been in
prison for two and a half years
and has no idea if his iraqi wife is
still alive
nor has he met his son i saw him in a
dream once
i have no idea what it looks like to be
honest and that's obviously hard to deal
with
that's sort of my life goal at the
moment
see my wife and child wherever it is
but he says no one's prepared to decide
what to do with him
and the home office won't comment on
individual cases
jack's parents received a 15-month
suspended sentence on friday
his mother sally lane told sky news on
the phone that she was incredibly
reassured to hear her son was well
it's been more than two years since they
spoke i really want to see them any more
than i've ever wanted to see them in my
whole life and
being more than two years not being able
to hear my like i said my mother's voice
is sort of a big deal for us
we were very close family and it's my
mum was my best friend now his mother
says the campaign will begin
to get him home the question is whether
he'd be welcome
emma birchley sky news